well back to uh Elder Scrolls star field
so one thing I didn't ask you about
when you look at the timeline of five
six seven eight years whatever it is to
create a game what's the role of the
deadline
internally not publicly enough to be
honest do you try to keep in your own
brain a deadline for the team a deadline
yeah all the time and when you set that
deadline early in the development
do you try to set deadline like that's
really tough to reach no we try to make
it like hey this is our best guess if
you make it tough to reach it's sort of
you know you're going to miss it it's
arbitrary
we really try to you know keep ourselves
honest because it will let you know
where you're at right when I first
playable we want to be done with
prototyping or design by this date we
want to have first playable this day we
want to have this but look you know
things happen pandemic happens people go
home it's throws everything off or
you know what you needed to do because
we're not just like making a game and
then moving everybody on you know what
you needed to do like Skyrim was so
popular we kept people on that game for
longer so it delayed a little bit we
were doing with Fallout 4 at the time
because we can't we're you know hey
we really shouldn't move the people on
The Fallout yet because we're doing
these things in Skyrim and we should so
it just sort of keeps you honest for
where you're where you're at does it get
super stressful as you get closer you
try to avoid announcing anything is
there a temptation to analysis well I've
done it always right I've I've announced
you know Starfield we're pretty you know
loud with a release date that we then
had a delay so
um was that tough
it was
it was but it was the right thing to do
and uh how do you know it's the right
thing like when you when you sat down
and looked at it like this is not ready
it's not an exact science but you can
look at what needs to be done and the
amount of time you have and you know
we've done it in the past where we can
get it done we we believe we can and so
you're fighting that personal belief
that you can get something done
but there's a lot of things that go into
release date with marketing and
Publishing
and
you know we've reached a point where on
Starfield where it was it was pretty
clear to us
even though you want to say you can get
it done that
the risk involved with that to the to
the fans of the game to the team to the
company we're part of Xbox now to
everybody was
we should really uh we should really
move it
and give it the time it needs